he's the head coach of my Dallas
Mavericks he's Rick Carlisle joining us
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
good morning Rick how's your shot right
now my shot as well Dan how about your
shot it's good I you know what I i'm
obsessed with perfecting it even at my
age I'm still looking for the perfect
shot
yeah you should watch Dirk Nowitzki's
documentary it's called the Nowitzki
they're perfect worth which means
Nowitzki the perfect shot it's very
interesting do you think that's the best
shot you've ever seen perfect shot
well the numbers don't lie on that one I
mean the guys scored 32 thousand points
and he probably scored 2/3 of them on
jump shots so I got a and and most of
the a lot of those shots were contested
so I got to believe it's if it isn't the
greatest it's certainly one of the
greatest yeah because I love having this
discussion because there are a lot of
great shooters in the history of the
game but if you were gonna teach
somebody the perfect jump shot and I
look at Ray Allen
Clayton if I take away Dirk who shot
would you say I want you to study that
that's the perfect shot Wow I think
there's about three or four guys you
could just kind of equally look at klay
Thompson Steph Curry you know Reggie
Miller was one of the greatest shooters
of all time but he had a little bit of a
unusual release Larry Bird you know is
one of the great shooters ever and I
know I missing some guys
but hey you know it's it's a great
discussion for sure well also now I look
at the Greek freak he's having that
three-point shot to his repertoire it's
not going to be fair if he becomes a
knockdown 3-point shooter Rick it may
not be fair now yeah I agree with that
you know one of the things I do on the
road is you know I go out and watch
teams warm up early just watch you know
kind of some of the routines and just
I get a feel for what's going on out
there and I saw a Yanis out there before
the game three nights ago working on the
three and he he made about eight or nine
out of ten I was just shaking my head
and covered my eyes no no no you know
and then he hit the first they hit the
first one he took that night you know
and then he missed a few so you know we
got it we got a little lucky there but
you know with his with his ability to
kind of create downhill situations and
euro-step and avoid charges and get
contact and now he's you know he's
making free throws consistently man oh
man what a player he also referred to
LeBron they play tonight as an alien is
is there anything LeBron could do where
you would say he's now the best player
who ever played the game oh gosh you
know these debates and discussions you
know they they turn and they turn and
work the media cycles you know as we all
know and I understand why you're talking
about
I will never engage in a those absolute
conversations because you know as time
goes on you get into more of these
discussions and I found this over the
last couple of years you know because we
had Dirk here and Dirk was always I was
always being asked about where he is on
the you know in the total scale of great
greatness and great players and stuff
like this and you know you know and who
are the top five ever and then and then
and then and then you know people get
into these discussions and you don't
even hear bill Russell's name or Wilt
Chamberlain's name you know it's it's
it's crazy and so I don't know and you
know LeBron is definitely in the top
tier there's no question about that but
but who do you who do you disclude from
the from the top tier you know and I'm
not and I'm not going there I'm just not
gonna do it if I if somebody didn't see
Larry Bird play and you were describing
him in his prime how would you describe
it the ultimate the ultimate winner the
guy he was a guy that had an iron will
and iron will to win and his
his moods were only geared toward
winning and losing and the other guy
that I've been around a lot who was very
very much like that was Jason Kidd you
know he just you know winning was the
most important thing he didn't care
about stats at all you know if you look
at Birds stats for his career you know
they're they're spectacular compared to
you know a lot of players but the thing
that the thing that stands out the most
is you know he was a two or three time
MVP he was a multiple Finals MVP and
then you look at the other things he was
Rookie of the Year you look at the other
things he did he became MBA coach of the
year he became NBA executive of the year
I believe I believe if you look at all
of those different honors and you look
at first team all-nba and you look at
all sir appearances and winner of the
three-point contest in its initial
stages I don't think you'll find a more
decorated person in NBA history than
Larry Bird he's done he's done at all
and he was pretty good at trash-talking
the very best yes what's the best one
you heard with bird I don't remember
which year was but he and age I think
we're both in the three-point contest
together and Larry Larry won that one
the one the contest and then one one day
we got on the bus and we're on the bus
for a few minutes and Larry said today
she goes hey Danny and Danny goes yeah
Larry goes who's the three-point King I
think it's like you know stuff like that
and you know I can't really do justice
to the exchange but it was you know and
when you get into the great players of
all time and
and trash-talking and innuendo and
context of stuff I mean you're gonna
come up with some great one-liners you
know across the board you know with all
these guys I still love the Xavier
McDaniel story that and I don't I don't
think you were with the Celtics at the
time but he he told x-men I was I was
that's a true story right he says 2x I'm
gonna get the ball right here I'm gonna
turn around oh shoot
i'ma shoot the right in your face
basically my paraphrasing here Larry no
that's exactly what happened and the
reason one of the reasons I remember so
well is it's one of the it's one of the
few games I actually played in in my NBA
career so I had a little bit a little
bit more of a of an exacting memory of
it but ya know we were in Seattle and of
a road trip
we actually got way behind Casey Jones
through through a bunch of us in there
and we got hot and got the game within a
possession or two and then you know the
Stars went back in and and I think it
was tight or we were down one I don't
remember exactly which but you know
Larry Larry came in and Larry walked
down to the floor and he said he acts he
goes I'm gonna get the ball right over
there I'm gonna shoot over he there's
nothing you can do about it and he got
it and shot it and made it yeah he's a
Rick Carlisle the Mavs head coach
joining his first time you saw Luke
Adamczyk on film what did you think well
I thought this guy is really skilled
he's very unique you know the again I
use the word context the context of the
film it was it was hard to tell
everything about him because of the
level of competition he was at which
wasn't it was an NBA competition it was
it was high-level European competition
he was playing a lot of point guard but
not all point guard
and you know I this is a this is an
ongoing discussion you know how this guy
ever slide to the third Pig and you know
my general managers the only guy that
had consistently told me going back to
you know probably two years now that as
we headed toward the 2018 draft and this
is Donnie Nelson he said I said look
who's who's the best player because you
know we were gonna be we were still in a
rebuilding mode we were we were not
gonna have a great record you know this
was going to be a discussion he said Don
judges he goes and it's not close
I said really okay and and and and you
know he it turned as it turned out he
was absolutely right but then he goes to
Cuban and says hey we got it we got to
make this trade we got to get this guy
well there was a there was a window of
opportunity right before the draft
started Atlanta was willing to swap
picks assuming that you know our guy was
there at 3:00 and their guy was there at
at 5:00 and so you know we made the deal
and you know I I think we're we're
ecstatic about the deal you know they
got an extra an extra pick out of it
and I think they're very happy you know
with with where they're at - I can't
speak to how they feel about about Don
tidge in particular but you know when
you do when you do deals with teams you
wanna you always want to do well on the
deal but the best deals are when they're
good deals for both teams you're also
looking at a situation where I don't
know how much it helped him if he had
played college let's say he played it
Duke for one year what he be as advanced
as he is now because he played against
this European competition for you know
what three or four years prior to
joining the NBA what's the hard question
I I think the end I think the the real
answer is you know had he come out of
you know the systems over there are so
different and because they is the kids
our playing club with club teams at age
13 14 it's just it's a madness a
question or a matter of which which
level of the club system you're at you
know he was you signed to Real Madrid at
a very young age like you know 13 14 or
something like that and he was used with
them for several years and you know once
you get in once you get in that system I
mean there's there's no there's no real
situation where you drop out of it and
go to college I mean in almost all cases
and so you know had he when he was of
college age done that I don't know if he
would have been eligible for college
because he had already been playing
professionals so it's it's probably more
of a moot discussion but had he had he
gone to you know had he been in the
American system and gone to high school
and then gone to college you know it's
very very hard to say because you know
that those three or four years that he
spent with Real Madrid you know he
wasn't playing a whole lot but he was
playing with some of the great players
in Europe at the time a few of the
greatest players in European history he
was playing it against those guys every
day it was a very very serious winning
professional situation and that really
you know that really prepared him for
NBA basketball you know social media and
the impact that it has on the game now
you know you obviously didn't have that
when you guys were playing but his
social media does it is it gonna put
more pressure on Luca he's got a lot of
he's got millions of followers here so
does that play a role at all or are you
aware of that as a head coach well I'm
aware just from the standpoint that you
know I know he has three million
Instagram followers and I know that his
followers you know love watching him
they love watching highlights they love
watching to step back threes and you
know all that said you know you do the
math
you do the calculation you know it just
it creates a lot a lot of demand for him
to generate highlights and and to do
those kinds of things you know
fortunately for us you know he doesn't
have to go out of out of the norm very
much I mean he just kind of plays that
kind of game anyway but it is a
different world now um everything
happens you know really in real time if
we pretend that that's not how the
world's working you know we're fooling
ourselves and so this is this all
factors into the equation for today's
young players and you know I'm always
you know adapting to you know the
changing environment in the world of
basketball you know you always a coach
you always try to stay ahead of it as
much as you can but you know sometimes
you simply got to absorb and adapt and
you know it's it's such a different
world now but it's very very exciting
because the game has never been more
exciting and we've got some young
players that are just you know so
dynamic obviously Dodgers included I
also I used to say this about Brett
Favre it felt like he needed degree of
difficulty like you know sometimes the
game comes to you a little too easy and
I wonder about with dhansak if it it's
gonna it comes to easy and then you get
bored to a certain degree and you want
to try new things there do you do you
caution him with that or is that is
something that I'm sort of pulling out
of the sky now it's a factor and this
was this was something that happened
with bird you know on the floor yeah he
just yeah and okay you know our team's
our Boston teams when I was on the team
then during the the you know 85 86 87
you know they were dominant teams there
were 60 plus win teams there were a lot
of nights where you were just simply
going to win the game because you had
more talent and and and you had you had
guys that were really geared toward
toward winning and you know Larry Larry
we're doing to a creative mode a lot of
times just because you know he did get a
little bored and
it's something that happens with great
players I mean it's it's something that
happens with Luca Diane and I have
talked to him about it
I acknowledge it and I also acknowledge
that you know he is an artist on the
floor he is a performer on the floor and
the thing that I'm I'm always reminding
him is that you know he is an artist but
he's he's paid to win and he and he is
paid to entertain but ultimately you
know winning winning is the most
important thing but as a 20 year old guy
you know he understands that he really
does and in his moods like Larry Bird's
like Jason kids you know are far more
influenced by winning and losing than
anything else and that's that's a really
exciting fact didn't bird shoot
left-handed for an entire game against
Portland
well it didn't quite go like that I
think I remember because I was there and
it was it was at a time when you know
McHale was still coming off the bench
and so he had he's were the first eight
points of the game left-handed in
general and Jerome Kersey was guarding
him at the time and I remember this
because we had a great trash-talking
team I mean we had ml car we had McHale
we had bird we had you know Ames was a
yaker I mean we just we had weird guys
with great creativity with that and I'll
never forget them but McHale yells out
hey throw a weightless or shoot radiator
you know I mean but you know you're
talking about you talk about one of the
great the great obviously great players
great competitors but bird was a great
artist too and and you know you know I
think I think LeBron James is is that
you know Kobe Bryant was
was an amazing artist on the floor you
know dodge it just certainly wanted one
of those guys as a great young player
you know there's a lot of them I mean
look tre Young's a great young talent he
does some amazing things out there you
look at what harden is doing I mean you
just go you could just go right down the
list and the NBA is so blessed it's
great to talk to you Rick we appreciate
your time and love the stories and thank
you for joining us
all right dance it's my pleasure take
care that's Rick Carlisle for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]